Transcriber: HİBA HIJAZI ŞEHAB
المدقّق: gaith Takrity
السلام عليكم جميعا.
بمعدل تسعة وتسعين فاصلة ثلاثة بالمئة.
تخرج خالد من المرحلة الثانوية.
هو ينتمي لأسرة متوسطة الدخل.
أب وأم وخمسة أشقاء وشقيقات.
طوال سنوات دراسته في مدارسنا الحكومية.
أثبت خالد تفوقه الأكاديمي،
وقدرته العالية
على الوصول لقائمة الأوائل في كل سنة.
خالد إنسان محب للأفلام
والمسلسلات الوثائقية.
وهو أيضا إنسان اجتماعي،
ملازم لوالده، وحريص على حضور مختلف
المناسبات الاجتماعية المنتظمة.
خالد إنسان قارئ، فهو يقرأ على
الأقل كتاب واحد كل شهر.
وهو إنسان ملم بأحداث العالم
وأخباره، ما يكون هناك خبر ولا حدث
حول العالم إلا وقرأ عنه وفكر فيه
وبحث عنه، وكون خلفية جيدة عنه.
حسنا.
ماهي مشكلة خالد؟
لا يوجد مشكلة، حقيقة خالد إنسان متعلم مثقف
اجتماعي، متحدث بارع،
محاور، متمكن عنده أفكار جميلة جدا
بل عميقة أحيانا.
مشكلة
إن خالد ليس هو خالد.
فكر وآراء ومبادئ وشخصية خالد،
صاغها وكتبها ونسقها بل وشكلها آخرون.
خالد لا يعي بأن أساس ذاته وأصل تكوينه،
وخلاصة فكره شكلت له،
مثل ما يتشكل السلايم،بعمد أحيانا
لكن في أحيان كثيرة بدون عمد.
خالد هو نموذج لكثير من الفخاريين
حول العالم التي تشكل لهم آرائهم،
وأفكارهم ووجهات نظرهم
بدون مؤامرت كونية
وبدون خطط في غرف مظلمة وبدون عمل شيطاني،
لكنها فقط ضعف القدرة المعرفية
والمهارات التحليلية،
افتقار للتفكير الناقد، والأهم
وجود قابلية عالية للتقولب(التشكيل)،
التقولب هو تشكيل لفكر
الإنسان وآراءه ووجهة نظره،
وشخصيته ومبادئه وقيمه، وفق توجهات وأعمال
وتيارات ومسارات خارجية بدون وعي ذاتي منه
هو شخصيا وبدون تحرص.
مع الوقت يقبل الإنسان بهذه الحدود
التي رسمت له.
ويقبل بوجود مثل هذه القوالب الجاهزة،
والأقفاص المرسومة فبالتالي
يفكر ضمن حدودها يبني شخصيته
على أساسها، لا يجرؤ على الخروج منها،
بل يدافع ويستميت بالدفاع عن
هذه الحدود والقوالب التي رسمت له من الآخر.
مع الوقت يؤمن بأن معتقداته وفكره
وآراءه ووجهة نظره وقيمه ومبادئه هي
مبنية على فكر،
واعتقاد ونقاش وعمق مقارنة، لكن الواقع
أن هذا الإنسان هو مجرد مجموع
لقوالب على هيئة بشر.
القابلية للتحول وسهولة التأثر بالآخر،
تتجلى في أبهى صورها عندما تفقد ملكة الشك،
الشك في أصل معلومة في مصدرها في طريقة
عرفها في توقيت ظهورها في القناة التي
تخرجها، في كيفية صياغتها وفي عشرات
المتغيرات التي تغير وترجح
هذه المعلومة عن غيرها.
هذا لا ينطبق فقط على المعلومات المحض،
لكنه ينطبق على القصة والإسهاب والشرح
والتفصيل وغيرها من عشرات
وسائل إيصال المحتوى .
هذه القابلية للتقولب لا يختص بها الأشخاص
أصحاب معدلات الذكاء المنخفضة، ولا يختص
فيها الأشخاص أصحاب التحصيل الأكاديمي
المنخفض، ولا يمكن أن نستثنيها من فئة
القراء أو المثقفين، بل ولا حتى النخب.
هي أشبه بالغشاء،
الذي يحيط بقلب المرء وبفؤاده،
فلا يستطيع أن يرى سواه
ولا يستطيع أن يراه إلا عن طريقه.
هذه القابلية للتقولب وسهولة التأثر
بالآخر، موجودة في جميع المجالات في
المجال الثقافي مثلا عندما يحيط الإنسان
نفسه بأشخاص لديهم نفس منهجية التفكير
والتعليل ، ومن ثم يقرأ في كتب منتقاة، ومن
ثم يقرأ للخصم عن طريق عدوه،
بدون الأخذ بالاعتبار التحيزات الشخصية
والإطار التاريخي،
ووجود عدد كبير من الاعتبارات والظروف
والمتغيرات لا بد أن يخرج الإنسان بطريقة
وبفكر
مقولب، جاهز، هش وسطحي.
الأمر سيان عندما ننظر تجاه التاريخ مثلا.
حين يقرأ الإنسان لمؤرخين أو كتّاب، بل
وحتى معاصرين،
بدون الأخذ بالاعتبار الخلفيات الشخصية
والتحيزات الذاتية،
والخليفيات العقدية والفكرية والسياسية
والدينية والظروف الراهنة،
والإطار العام.
لمثل هذه الكتابة
لا بد وأن تحصل هنالك ألفة اتجاه تيار معين،
وبالتالي قولبة وبالتالي فكر هش، سطحي،
جاهز ومقولب.
هذه القولبة تحصل في جميع المجالات، في
المجال الثقافي والفني والفكري والفلسفي،
في المجال الحضاري في المجال التراثي، بل
وحتى في أبسط الأمور،
في مجال التعاملات الشخصية.
الشخص المقولب لا يعي بأن الشخص الذي
الأمامه مهما كان لديه من التحيزات الشخصية،
ولديه من الأفكار المسبقة، ولديه
من الترسبات الفكرية والمعتقدات الراسخة،
ما يجري الحديث معه عن أي محتوى كان.
يفتقر للحيادية ويفتقر للموضوعية ولو
كان يتحدث عن غذائه بالأمس.
هذا لا يحدث بتعمد ولا بقصد من الشخص
الملقي، ولكنها طبيعة النفس البشرية
واللاوعي البشري لا بد و أن تلقي بظلالها،
على أفكار المرء وأطروحاته وبطريقة عرضها
وأسلوب إظهارها للآخر.
إذا ما هو الحل؟
عند وجود إشكالية بهذا الحجم،
في وجود قابلية لدى الكل للتقولب
من قوالب جاهزة،
ماهو الحل؟ كيف نقلل، ولا أقول نمنع
ولكن نقلل قابليتنا للتقولب؟
هناك عدة عوامل تؤخذ في الحسبان.
لكن لعل أهم هذه الاعتبارات،
هي قضية ترسيخ مفهوم الشك
لدى النفس البشرية، ولا أقصد الشك
في وجود نوايا مبطنة، ولكن الشك في
وجود تحيزات ذاتية،
الشك في وجود معتقدات راسخة أفكار مبطنة،
لاوعي شخصي وذاتي
يجعل تناول أي محتوى كان يفتقر للحيادية
الموضوعية،
وبالتالي نتعامل معه على هذا السياق.
مع الوقت يصبح تكلف الشك
مهارة وقدرة، فما يطرح من رأي
ولا تناقش فكرة إلا نظر لها بعين الشك،
بعين فاحصة، بعين تنظر
لعشرات المتغيرات، التي
ولابد أن تغير في مستوى وقيمة
موضوعية وحيادية هذا الطرح.
وكما هو الحياد مستحيل.
كذلك براءة الطرح مستحيلة.
من المهم أن يكون في الحسبان، عند النظر لأي
محتوى، بغض النظر عن ماهية المحتوى ذاته
سواء كان محتوى نخبوي أو
كان محتوى شخصي فردي.
لا بد أن ينظر لهذا المحتوى وفق اعتبارات
كثيرة، وفق ظروفه الراهنة،
وفق إطارها العام، وفق اعتبارات شخصية، وفق
تحيزات شخصية
وفق نظرة مختلفة،
أفكار راسخة، ترسبات فكرية،
أهداف مبطنة، أهدف قد
لا تكون متعمدة مفتعلة كما هو الحال
في كثير، بل والأصل أن تكون هذه الأهداف
تلقائية وعفوية وغير مقصودة .
في الختام .
في النهاية لا يسعني إلا أن أقول لكم،
شكرا جزيلا لاستماعكم.
وأختم بكلمة أقول لا تكونوا مثل خالد .
شكرا جزيلا .
(تصفيق)